you guys today's episode is sponsored by
better help which is a customized online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see anyone if you
don't want to this podcast is sponsored
by better help and trash tuesday
listeners get 10 off their first month
at betterhelp.com trash tuesday giving
the gift of therapy guys it's
an honor
our show is sponsored by our favorite
drink liquid death
oh mango are you serious we love their
three new flavors mango chainsaw severed
lime and bury it alive a mango a mango
it's delicious you know what i liked
about this it's got an island vibe it
feels like kalila had to climb up a tree
to pick this for me i did climb up a
tree to pick it just for her
you guys can get free shipping on all
waters and merch at liquid death dot com
slash trash that's liquid death dot com
slash trash or find liquid death at
7-eleven target albertson safeway or
amazon you guys this podcast is
sponsored by dipsy
go to dipsystories.com
tuesday you're going to want to dipsy
inside yourself when you watch dipsy let
me tell you that dipsy is an app full of
hundreds of short sexy audio stories
designed by women for women they bring
scenarios to life with immersive
soundscapes and characters no matter who
you're into or what turns you on and for
listeners of this show dipsy is offering
an extended 30-day free trial when you
go to dipsysstories.com
tuesday that's 30 days for full access
for free when you go to dipsy that's
d-i-p-s-e-a
stories dot com slash tuesday you can
see me this very weekend in houston
texas at the improv june 10-12 they
somehow got me a sunday show please come
on the lord's day
burbank california on june 18th we're
going to sell that out it's going to be
so fun
west nile new york the 24th through the
25th then in august i'm taking july off
and then i'm going to be in august i'm
going to be in austin texas springfield
missouri and then after that you can
look at my website i'll be in pittsburgh
tempe
uh caluso california kansas city irvine
michigan grand a bunch of places and i'm
so excited i can't wait to see you
andyletterman.com
hi slugs i'm going on tour you can get
tickets at esteronice.com i'm coming to
austin in dc and i'm always adding more
and i have a clothing line sleepover by
esther.com check it out and enjoy this
episode it's as it's as chaotic as ever
you guys um bobby and i are going to be
at the ace theater in los angeles on
june 25 this is our first real
road date that we've ever done in all of
the seven however long eight years we've
been doing this it's gonna be so fun
it's gonna be unlike what you expect it
to be
um we might have some special guests so
go to
tigerbellylive.com go get your tickets i
cannot wait to see you hug you
and um i'm back out in the real world so
this is your opportunity to come say hi
and
you know maybe get a hug out of me and
bobby so see you there
[Music]
wait um
is it bad though that i'm now suddenly
in a phase where i'm drinking two
coffees a day like how that's better
than most americans yeah i think two
cups is good really
two cups is like two two cups i would be
like it would be normal right yeah like
doctors would be like don't have more
than two cups what time of day do you
drink i like to do you know my morning
one for my anti-sadness walk and then uh
like a three or four p.m that sounds
that's late
do you sleep
that's i would do before i would do
before four or before three eventually
so you guys live like late night lives
that's a thing annie is like no why
don't you join us you [__]
can i just
be with us sometimes you [__] [__]
we're having the times of our lives and
you're not even seeing it because she's
not a stand-up comedian but just come on
[__] push on stage and poke at you
that's what bobby's been saying he's
like you know we've been together for so
long and you've been to the comedy store
like four times it's the most fun ever
it's the most fun time ever you know
what i sleep very late
wait you have the most fun time ever at
the comedy store i don't believe you
i think you're giving her no sets by the
way emily
she gets no set she's an in great stupid
[__] i would like to do one half hour
honestly i'll still go esther can't
listen she would love that would be your
favorite set if i did it i know
what i feel like i've done this before
loki where you'll be up after me and i i
feel like i've genuinely said like if
you want an extra five minutes like
esther i would totally charge the
mountain and by the way it's never an
accident i have i have tex in here where
i'm like put me and esther and bobby and
santino all together oh that's so sweet
you're all the people i like to like
come and just like sexually harass on
the way
annie i um you're the only comic i know
that lives in late night comic life but
still gets up before anyone mental
illness i don't even know what to say
wait wait a second so like how much
sleep does your body actually require
where you feel rested fully rested okay
i could do four hours it's not ideal but
that's a sleep cycle four hours is a
sleep cycle that's why you have to get
eight right so four would be better than
honestly six four oh okay but i still
try to get the most i can but it i'm
less sleepy if i do four things i know
what you mean it's it's the same as like
um
for me getting up
yeah the six and a half hour mark if you
try to wake me up at that point i'm
groggy because i'm probably deeply in
rem or i don't know where i am in my
sleep cycle but is there anything she's
all in the ocean she's all swimming
she's [__] a fish
she's banging a fish she's scaring it
while she's [__] it it's dying while
she's banging it bless you
tiny baby bless you did that not annoy
anyone else i was fully annoyed by that
i was like is she being fake
fake sneeze do you you know the fake
sneeze people though i don't really
think you are one but you're fake
sneezers
you know the people that do you trained
yourself to be a sneezer wait my aunt
was like that and was she married to the
murderer no she's like whatever i can do
to get attention she's married bloody
sneeze
yeah she was like
rant like how her husband did she was
married to um a german man named otto
immune
disorder
otto um but um yeah she would do that so
she'd be like
it's like a [__] yeah that's hot
oh
esther will you try can i prescribe you
trying to do that sneeze for the next
three months i'll try but i think it's
to be expected from you i think you
think that people can dictate how they
say they can't know
i think annie's right it's fake yeah why
was it cool stomach aches and headaches
were the worst thing to have because
there's no evidence of them
i had headaches and people were like
wait i told you that i had to wear
sunglasses in
school
for why i had i had headaches and my the
uh fluorescent lights would trigger them
so i just was for like seventh grade i
was just the coolest kid well isn't it
or the blind kid don't fluorescent
lights cause cancer like those old
school bulbs or
like they don't use them the ones that
like the ones with the ones on our line
george
ultraviolet radiation emitted by
fluorescent lighting can increase an
individual's exposure to carcinogenic
greedy okay oh this is like why we're
not supposed to get gel manicure and eat
bacon because uv light is bad for us but
what about gel x
that is anytime you're getting a uv
light
x is like the x's on your eyes when
you're dead from it
an old cartoon joke of all the things
like you know we when of all the six
symptoms which
of them are you the most intolerable of
like for me it's a sore throat
i love this question i cannot deal with
sore throats sore throat is really high
up there um
clogged up nose is also really bad i
think you're right that sore throat is
the worst period pain is very like you
can't do anything about it but
like i'd rather have that than a sore
throat
cluster headaches to me are the worst
just because i throw up i can't go
anywhere like i have to get whitney like
sent me a nurse to like give me a shot
in my ass that did nothing but it was so
nice of her you know yeah headaches is a
close second especially when you have
your house yeah or open your eyes
probably or want to live you want to be
dead yeah just cut the head off but what
did i want to say about what were your
ones that you just said i think it's
sore throat because like
i just also what's associated with that
to me is like the first day of the cold
taking a big [__]
that doesn't hurt my throat actually
that would help a sore throat don't
actually don't when you do have a sore
throat aren't you like i just want to
blow someone like
suck this pain out of my [__] throat
like scratching we usually just manuka
honey for me
oh my god guys
dip your dicks and manuka honey and save
your girlfriend's throat yeah is there
since you brought up manuka honey i
actually have a question i've been
saving is it jason manuka honey what is
my name
okay manuka honey is just like this i'm
curious if there's any truth behind it
because basically it's like 80 honey
that comes only from new zealand and
they say it has medicinal properties
but i'm like isn't it just sugar and
honey or am i actually can i actually
eat this and feel good about it
um
honey fear no but i'm like is this a way
to have pure sugar
and not feel naughty okay once in
college they had a nutritionist come and
i don't know why we were in the library
also the college went out of business so
who knows but
she was like she's like
if you have two spoonfuls of honey she
didn't
differentiate the type but she said
if you have two spoonfuls of honey in
the morning like you won't get sick
i never did it
i've thought about it since this moment
but
i just like the way honey coats my
throat what does it do it does save
everything yeah it's very yeah it it you
know when you're you feel like you're
swallowing glass like the first or
second day of a sore throat you wake up
in the morning everything's just dried
and painful like there's times where you
have to hold your nose it hurts so much
like in your sleep yeah manuka honey on
hot water and like lemon sort of just
soothes your pathways really nicely
okay i know you're
horny a
pathway opening up in your videos no
even worse i was like oh i hope i get
sick soon
don't worry you will
then i can go back on my day quilt wait
should we talk about how we killed ray
like ray leota oh my god you guys
you
one pock mark at a time i took him out
yeah so if people don't know last the
last episode from last week we talked
about ray leota and then the day after
we recorded that he passed away
he's dead and so people were asking like
did they know was this before or after
that was before
not that we wouldn't have said the jokes
but it would have been more
aimed at a dead person not at a living
and we love rightly oda well here's the
pattern on our daddy we miss him we love
our pockmark daddy we love our punk mark
daddies
there's a pattern there's a pattern
because the last time annie spoke about
this guy in a very and we we found out
on google that he had passed as well oh
my finger guy yeah the finger clip with
that i got it you guys look forward to a
clip of the fingering being fingered by
a dead man yeah remember oh i remember
she brought up a guy she hooked up with
and through carlos's googling carlos was
like oh um
it's kind of funny that carlos had to
deliver that news live on this show
deaf
is he dead did he do it did he die
it's just like is there better content
than someone has
our relationship was already so wild me
and this guy
but r.i.p that guy
plain finger guy
guys i got a mouth guard and it gives me
a lisp
can we listen
i'm supposed to wear it all the time i
was like i was like i can't wear it on
my podcast because people will stop
listening to it
i don't know what the movie revenge of
the nerds is about but this feels like
that's what it is for me right now
what is the revenge of the nerds about
oh it's nerds taking
revenge
at who and how
but how are they doing
it's like really like it's it would be
considered problematic now i hate best
friends and nerds lewis and gilbert
um and roland adams college sounds about
right peter gilbert
oh okay they go against the fraternity
as well yeah
80s frat movie it was great but there i
mean i'm sure it was like
slurs galore but anyway so i'm in the
doctor's office the the dentist's office
and they're like oh we fit your mouth
guard for you and they put in i go i
have a lisp and they're like no you
don't i go
you cannot gaslight me when i can't say
the word gaslight like for you to like
he's like you don't have a list that
sounds good i'm like i'm spitting um by
the way i just gotten i can't wear it
i also think that this is the white way
the more you wear it that's what they
said but how how
that's i can't answer that and because
why do i why would i i kept being like
well what gives a person a lisp it's is
it because their
two front teeth aren't touching it's not
going to touch
oh i look cool
you have the same one as curry but
here's the thing that is not he is in
person he that man is and his wife are
such cuties
oh yeah you met them
oh you messed up yeah
curry yeah bobby and i did their show
and my god are they just cutie pies and
also like you can tell genuinely like
are fully [__] oh you know what i
mean when people have been together in
long run you gripped when you said yeah
like they just started into each other
i'm like oh
everyone wants i think we should auction
this pillow off because everybody wanted
to be the pillow oh really i gathered
into the comments you guys and they were
fun we'll raise money off those yes the
vagina because gets none of it
she won't come to the comedy store guys
oh my god watching back
i know that's so hard oh wow wait you
know what the hottest thing that do you
guys remember the vmas when
ryan gosling and jennifer and and uh
what's the girl from the notebook
rachel
adams were dating and they went they won
for best kiss and he will you play this
video it's literally the hottest thing
i've ever seen did they really play the
video it's it's crazy this is i'll show
you what's hot about him watch right now
you're about to see it
oh god i'm getting horny
she's so oh my god beautiful don't worry
about her getting ready she is a
byproduct of something so look okay
ready watch
it's chewing gum it's the gum chewing
and the fur it's the gum chewing look
the nose grab
oh he [__] good
he's a dancer or a child dancer
i love him what's turned on oh he [__]
good oh yeah i have critiques oh i don't
like this kiss the gum chewing all of it
why can't we reenact the duster because
it's not two girls
because
because i don't like that they like
presented it they got ready like i
wanted to just kind of come out of
nowhere and be like disgusting
i have a new pitch for a kiss you would
like can you put on never been kissed
kiss
i wanted to there's no pause with this
here's what i want i want them to be
like
standing there no
no
like i wanted to be like they're
standing there and they're like this
yeah oh my god i really grabbed her hair
i'm sorry i felt good though
a little bit like that could hurt like
you want there to be no pause because
there's no pause
thank you by the way watch look look
look
he doesn't stop
i'm not aggressive enough
i mean you run aggressive yeah i grabbed
your hair and at first you were like no
but you liked it yeah of course okay
that's like what hair grabbing is right
it like hurts a little but it's like
yeah but it doesn't hurt that it's like
being slapped by the way ryan gosling
did not get hot to me until the movie
drive
drive when he stomped that face in
no annie when he had brain matter on the
bottom
you didn't see the [__] movie i
actually did that was one of your three
movies i went on a date which is so
weird that's the best soundtrack ever
too
yeah the soundtrack it makes me really
like downtown l.a too
now i want to have a sleepover and watch
drive
[Laughter]
i think that's always been my favorite
part of um being single and rebellious
is just the making out part never the
sex yeah like try humping have you made
guys come in their pants yeah those are
the things that kneecaps baby
i've had dudes come on my kneecaps oh
because you're well no if we're dry
humping you know and they're like oh
your legs and then i just got my name i
feel like there was a fun era in my time
my teacher came on my kneecap
excuse me
what's the opposite of a kneecap
but i know what you're talking about
because i feel like i had a fun era in
my early 20s where it's like oh i'm like
a single adult i can just kiss people
and it's like oh i never learned that
what i was always like you know next
morning i was like why did i [__] this
dork
i was like oh
no i had a few of those there was one
there was this kid i got really drunk at
a bowling alley with my
my like friends from middle school
i went back like during college and i
lost my glass like i was just such a
wreck and i went home with this like
kind of nerdy kid but he was like
low-key hot under the very thick thick
thick glasses he had like he had like
his eyes looked all big
but i was like there's something and he
had been like the biggest nerd in high
school it's like your type
which by the way josh potter's so happy
you said that he's like she's i'm her
fetish
but um
he drove me home and
yeah we made out we dry humped in and
his car and then he came in his pants
and i told everyone isn't that the best
it was so funny i just we were just like
playing
we were just rolling the ball and i was
looking at him i have a question why is
it that us women find a lot of pride and
joy when dudes come early and we make
them come but dudes don't necessarily
find the same joy not all now it's
changing a lot of men now want to like
pleasure a woman and make her come but
still the ratio is off that is weird we
have a friend who like revealed to us a
couple months ago that he's never asked
a girl if she's came before oh my god
are you how old he didn't mean to tell
his 30s say it without saying it it's
the leather jacket that told me and
we were carlos and i were just like
so blown away and
i don't know it just i never want to
know this person ever in my life
because i think that's a parallel and
that's
that will extend in all other parts of
his life if you cannot ask somebody that
you're being intimate with if they are
feeling
good
how what does that say because you're
really a sock to them you're a [__]
sock they could be jerking off you could
be a crunchy sock yeah please i never
want to know him never introduce me to
that person like why would you want to
have sex with someone
why would you want to if you're not
invested in their feeling good because
like you said we so where we like it if
a guy like comes yeah it's like that's
what i just can't imagine in any other
way give me my prize like i'll just jerk
off
yeah if it's not about
it's like about both of you
i'm all three of you whatever it is
three of you
i met all three of us sorry love you
guys but
no boys allowed
when esther comes there are no boys
allowed
girls sleepover only
um yeah no i it like when guys like egos
are attached to making you come that's
the best
i yes like it's like their pleasure is
about your pleasure but there are also a
lot of men who don't have a warped idea
of sex that truly get off when they're
eating you out right yeah and that's the
generally the kind of men that i that i
like to be with yeah and a lot of guys
just don't know how to do it and they're
like insecure like i think and then they
just like
i think that perpetuates them being like
shitty
lovers because they feel like they're
gonna be bad at it anyway
and but there's a book what is it she
comes first
it's got like a papaya on it
well what's funny to me is i'm like i
think we talked about this even like
when we were on schultz's podcast like i
think guys think that like their dick is
enough
like they just think that like i'm gonna
[__] you and like that's gonna be good
enough it's like that's never enough we
use a back massager that's the size of
like a baseball bat
there's a back massager that is what is
it called the magic wand okay there's no
want a fairy isn't able to lift that one
it's so heavy it's like
so superpowered you think your dick
is enough well here's why i'll i'll go
as far as saying that
um that canal is meant for
birth right it can take a large
dense mass coming out of it but i'm just
thinking of like being [__] with a
baby
why did i go there she said it and not
me
you're changing and you're changing in a
really good way
you're changing in the right direction
that's not what i want to hear from you
it's good esther it's good
well
yeah so um there was another animation
no no no the woman on tick tock was
basically like
um there are size queens women that just
prefer the idea of a big dick but there
are no real nerve endings in that canal
for good reason because we're they're
supposed to take a [__] beating when
the baby comes out so really our nerve
endings are more obviously in like the
outer areas and like our lips and right
at the entry of it which is why i really
stand by what i say like
big dicks small dicks it doesn't matter
for me in fact the the if you're a four
and a half or less you'll probably make
me come faster why is that
because it where the dick enters where
it enters it for me it has to be like
right okay wait if this is the [__] of
my vagina it's like this entry
this part exactly it's like exactly mine
too like if you even just you know what
soaking is no it's a mormon term where
you're not because they kind of get away
with not [__] fully so they just
stretch underwear is mormon right now oh
my god they just soak it so you just put
the dick in and you don't move what so
you don't move i come
keegan if you just put it right at the
tip because the the entry point is where
a lot of my nerves are and i kegel and
then that's it yep
i have a lot to discover later tonight
i'm very curious what you mean but i had
a boyfriend with a monster [__] and i
will say
that's pretty good that's pretty good
too i think i just like it
what what
what are you laughing at it was crazy it
was amazing
it was amazing
and it was like i don't need this it was
a lot like it was a lot the [__]
were i mean let's just say i'm dealing
with it now
i'm let's just say i sucked a dick
mental health is an issue for all of us
big time for me that is why i'm so
grateful we're sponsored by better help
i'm doing a lot better actually because
of better help i agree i'll leave you
guys in the dust you guys this podcast
is sponsored by better help online
therapy and what better help is it's
basically
um
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to and for me lately that's been the
case i just want to be in a dark corner
on the phone crying to my therapist and
that's available to you through better
help
i have to say my life has improved
drastically since i have taken action to
talk to someone about what i'm going
through and getting that off my mind and
off my chest just like
it's made me able to think more clearly
and make better decisions for myself and
i like better help because it is a more
affordable option to do that right and
sometimes you know um you know we often
hear the word burnout but burnout can
look so many different ways like even if
you're operating at your optimal level
or so it seems burnout might be right
around the corner from that yeah if you
let things bother you all day like i
always notice i have all these triggers
and i'm just triggered all day and then
i'm exhausted at night because i've just
given up all of my peace and to be able
to talk to someone talk that out see
what that's about and what i can do to
not it'll really improve your life for
the better and listen we get burned out
at work do you think it's easy working
with these [__] it's burnout central
you guys and i'm telling you that um
at least for me um i absolutely need um
a resource and betterhelp has been that
resource for me for several years now
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and trash tuesday listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday that's b e t t e r h e l p
dot com slash trash tuesday
you [__] [__]
it's just water it's just water esther
oh
liquid death so you can be cool at a
party and drive home safe
[Laughter]
you guys they have options now they have
my favorite the flat mountain water they
have the sparkling but now they have
three new flavors a berry me alive is it
berry meal it's very italian bury it
alive mango chainsaw and the third is
severed lime
and you know what it feels like it feels
like there has been a chainsaw to my
mango because it has been split by my
pants i am having the most painful camel
toe of my life but guys
you know what makes me feel better
liquid dad i find them the new flavors
to be so good for like mixing drinks and
i don't even drink alcohol but i like to
make mocktails so i'll do the severed
lime and i'll mix it with cranberry
juice and it is so good it's like tart
and sweet and perfect
we love liquid death here at this show
you guys know i'm always drinking it as
you probably see on social media and i
just like that
it's a can i can drink it and especially
when i'm out and people are not like oh
she's not drinking she's not cool it's
like no i'm actually cooler than you no
they think you're not old enough to
drink they're like how did this underage
girl get here it's gold are you kidding
this is awesome and also i'm i'm that
person that
i never know what to do with my hands in
the social um setting so if they're not
i thought you were really i thought you
knew exactly what to do it's called
skiing that's a different life
um but i i'm always social i'm awkward
i'm not what do i do with my hands i
always feel like i need to carry a drink
this is the perfect solution to that be
the cool person in the room get free
shipping on all water and merch at
liquiddeath.com
trash that's liquiddeth.com
trash or find liquid death at 7-eleven
target albertson safeway or amazon
i am in [__] tmj health
but um
it fills you to the brim it's crazy it's
like that part of your every part of
your vagina is being touched by the i
think that there are some
it's not honestly i'm not a size queen
but
i can't
i'm a size king uh bed is what i have
have you guys ever cause i sometimes if
i'm watching porn and the guy's dick is
too big i literally can't watch it
because i'm just like out ow that hurts
that hurts like it i can't well a big
dick to you would be what two and a half
inches oh my gosh
but do you ever see a dick that's so big
that you're like
change so when i watch porn i cannot
change the channel it's just on regular
tv
if there was a box do you have
if i could um describe a porn that would
cater directly to me all the dude's face
would be blurred out
yes i don't like dudes faces that i
don't know it's almost like who are you
i don't trust you why am i you know it's
it's
i don't want to see your [__]
expressions i don't know you know what i
my only criteria for
porn is that the girl has a real orgasm
that's my only it has to be she's having
a real orgasm oh what are you guys and i
need to see and believe she's having an
orgasm
i can and i will try to have an orgasm
at the same time yes okay that i do i
try to time it usually when the guy is
coming though right but she's saying
when that's oh misogynist yeah i am
internalized misogyny so when he's
coming i then i come
i like to time it the rhythm
i could go either way i'm gonna
i really do want to have um i got one of
those things
the ceramic pentameters what are those
dynamics
what are they called what did you get
tick tick tick tick to keep count oh
like on garageband yeah i want to use
that because i'm like
because i have way worse rhythm than
everyone i've ever [__] in my life
like they really got to take me i got to
be like oh
no you don't need rhythm for sex
i'll show you cowboy take me away that's
nuts
that's what it looks like a metronome my
camel toe is so crazy right now i want
to ask you guys so i was watching this
one um porn the other day
it's a cow toe and it's um it's a page
on pornhub it's called my sweet apple
and one of the girls
i'm so interested what is this my sweet
apples i was watching one where they
were in the pool it was two girls and
one guy because that that's what i'm
into i like it when the other girl like
spreads the other girl and the guy goes
in it's my thing wish he hadn't had wish
his head was cut off but you know
um
um i made concessions but one of the
girls had an obvious hemorrhoid and i
loved it i loved that she i'm like
finally a porn i can get into no it's
like yes [__] yes well i do have to
feel like i'm in it like i have to feel
like i can be in it like p i don't want
pov because it's just like a scary guy
but
i do have to feel like it's a sex i
could be having
yeah i think my sweet apple does a good
job but i like amateur too i don't like
any sort of professional [__] wait do
you watch only fans porn this one my
sweet apple i watch on pornhub okay
esther's like i'm not the only fan
i have i will admit i have subscribed to
girls only fans yeah who do we have
i'm not gonna say who because she's
friends with them which is so creepy
that's so awkward like i always think
about that i'm like
dude you just like subscribed to like
the it's just i think like i guess i
thought over the pandemic that like
things were going to come back regular
and like the girls that were doing only
fans were going to have to like go back
to their office jobs and like everyone
in the cubicles around them were going
to be like
hey [__]
seen it seeing it all right i don't
think there's no work anymore nobody is
i don't think i would tell them the
people that i know that i've subscribed
but i think if it came up i would just
be like i would like feel it out but i
don't want to make anyone uncomfortable
but yeah also there's been
um
i've subscribed to a certain only fans
like that i knew dave was curious about
and so just to be like sweet i was like
here i still or were you like faking
that you were like into the same thing
as him no it's like when someone's like
my favorite movie is rushmore like no me
too
ten years in there's no faking that i
like things like trust me i try uh there
was faking actually we did go to
whitney's house for todd's birthday
which by the way i can't wait to unfold
this story
so i text whitney i really like
whitney's boyfriend
he's a cool guy this guy alex he's a vet
not a veteran he has his legs
um he is a veterinarian
and so for todd's birthday i was like
hey do you want to just go on like a
double date or something and whitney is
like that's not enough for whitney she's
like double date she's like let's just
have a party over at my house and she
has just renovated her house it's
beautiful it's amazing always a good
time at whitney's house
so i was like oh okay and then she's
like who do you wanna invite and i just
it literally was only you guys and your
boyfriends yeah we're the only i was
like i can't even think of anyone else
yeah um pete didn't cross my mind guys
sorry uh
i was i could have went
nobody it's for todd's birthday okay his
present was not inviting you uh i'm just
kidding
but i invited carlos he couldn't go
yeah you have a bad friend right here
but so
so that was on like a sunday todd's
birthday was on a tuesday okay monday
morning i get a text from whitney that
says hey i'm having people over on
tuesday do you want to come let me go
oh boy you've forgotten what how this
started and she went oh whoa
oh i thought tom's birthday was on
wednesday i'll push it i go no just keep
the party it's fun just
whatever so whitney had already
forgotten that it was for todd because
she can't help herself
and but it ended up being the most fun
it was it was fun yeah it was a good
night and dave was there reading in the
corner esther pretending that she's
someone that serves
dave may i give you another did you want
the corn i mean it was so fake it was
the fakest thing you've ever seen you
know why
that happened is because
i could tell
that he wanted more food but he's so oh
he's like he's so polite it was driving
me he's so polite and like kind of shy
that i was like this is where i shine
where i can be the aggressive not shy
one i was like no problem dave i'll get
you so i that came out of me every time
dave had the urge to be like esther
that's not like
i was like yes
go go go we get there and whitney will
like she could possibly forget to
service food like
whitney's had parties where it's like
we're going to watch a movie and like
there's no movie there's no way to watch
it there's not possibly going to happen
and so
esther goes like uh like anyone hungry
like she was like doing that and dave
was like that's so rude i'm like damn i
wanna [__] kill you
we need esther right now we're all
[__] starving yeah no i have a
lifelong commitment to always being
willing to be the person at a party or
event that's like where's the food
annoying
i'm always willing to go first even
though my dad has like that's he always
take the last bite
yeah i will always take that i'm like
we're gonna get let it get cold
oh yeah i'm gonna take the last bite
[__] yeah i'm like i'm not gonna play
that game yeah because it is it's not
it's not like you're selling yourself
out but i come from a different culture
where if you do not go straight for the
food you're being rude
so
so you if let's say for instance you've
already had breakfast lunch and dinner
and then a late night snack and my mom
comes to you and says hey esther are you
hungry you're supposed to say yeah i'll
take whatever
you're being served okay i don't care if
you don't eat it all but don't say no
like food is food is a love language for
filipinos and so it's like receive our
love
i will admit i have gotten into trouble
and on that end of it where i've been
offered food and i wasn't hungry
and then i'm like later i'm like i this
has happened in my family too where i'm
like oh [__] it's rude not to eat the
food but i'm like i have eating rhymes
with food
come on i think it's for me what i do in
those situations where i'm clearly full
to the brim and i cannot have any more
and like let's say atita's like kalaila
here's some more food i'd like oh thanks
tita and then i'll grab the food and
i'll look at jules or bobby or somebody
like you gotta [__] help me with this
okay like you do
okay cool that's a good i'm gonna i'll
take the food and then make davey did
our dogs were there
donuts snapped at randy it was so cool
it was really cute and dave was like oh
i feel bad for dogs it's like no no no
this is the joy of our lives to see
rooney get snapped up so funny randy's
like me like you gotta slap you guys
snap at him he'll just go and go and go
but it was so fun kesha was there we had
a good time yeah it was a really fun
alex cooked it was great did you get
your animals i got my animal card
reading can you explain what that is
because
it's they're animal cards that so
whitney's lawyer was there
with his family
and his bentley saw it uh i know i saw
bentley and i think it's tim dillon yeah
but i was like this seems too new i know
his was like a 2018. but it seems like
it's like a tarot card reading or
something i've never done that but
this this girl who like i know what
they're called here let me find the
specific kind because she drew them so
the daughter of the
the lawyer
drew them illustrated them and then her
friend who she facetimed this girl anna
this girl face timed in and then they
would like do a reading on each of us
she'd pull a card and i think i got like
the jaguar
and facetimed yeah yeah why wasn't she
just there because she lives somewhere
else yeah whitney was being so mean to
her in the funniest way like whitney was
in that card room whitney is the
funniest i've ever seen her whoa i
missed it
it was she was like she's like i love
how you're just in like a free people
bra and the girl was like oh i'm sorry i
was watching game of thrones with my
[__] husband when he's like we get it
you have a husband [__] like the whole
thing was just it was good wait and so
you pulled a jaguar yeah and then like
have you ever done a psychic or tarot
card reading um i try not to
yeah because i noticed that the other
girls there were really scared before we
did it and i was like what's going on
they were scared i'm not scared of it
like the devil i just no we know you're
scared of the devil here's what i do i
go i go is this tarot card reading good
i believe in tarot card is this tarot
card reading bad tara's [__]
i i think i'm probably the same exactly
i don't buy into that i had never done
it and i'm not like a big
believer in that kind of stuff but i did
enjoy trying to find meaning but it's
fun yeah i like them because you know
what it is it's like
it's a guide you know it's like
something that you can so the plate it's
called animal guides
the website is animalguides.co
[Music]
animalguides.com what does the jaguar
mean it i think it meant
that i am like
i don't i'm like looking at carl's like
he was there meant to date a younger
woman
[Laughter]
um
i think it was about are they beautiful
oh they're so pretty see i'd get them
just because yeah i want to get them oh
and then i got that snake one too and it
was like about shedding a skin oh i
didn't know it was rainbow colored oh
man wow you got a pride snake
and
i don't know like i tried to find
meaning what they were saying i to be
honest like i look at that stuff sort of
similar to how i look at santa claus
like
tread lightly okay we have a lot of
children watching this
it's like i'll have fun and participate
and and enjoy the presents that santa
brought and and
enjoy it but like
but did you believe in santa when you
were a kid i think when i was really
little but not for long my parents did i
was not the kind of kid that had like
fantasies for like we you know remember
we determined that she was the girl who
told all the kids that santa's not real
you definitely did i remember that
picture of you when you were a kid you
were like a little bully
what picture just the cute picture of
you when you were a kid you know what
i'm talking about
you posted it where i was molesting
little girls yes the grim groomer
now um did you get todd anything for his
birthday
i got him pork roll egg and cheese and
he got to make it himself it's like
todd you're the caregiver here
i saw you give him here
i saw you give him your backs for him to
rub it oh he was giving me a massage on
his own birthday i was like do i have it
made here
no i made him a little todd montage that
i posted on instagram that he's really
excited about because he's so funny in
it and then um i really it's like what
do you get someone that you i'm like i
paid your rent i don't know it's i
every day is todd's birthday
todd todd is a
genuinely
happy soul he's the best yeah yeah it's
very very nice to be around
i feel like todd is that rare person
where i'm like he could just always be
around me and it would be i would never
be bothered by it no it's the greatest
he's so funny yeah he's not intrusive
bobby loves todd i know he's so good
and he's asian
yeah
how fun is that
yes
i love green arrow one bananas
[Music]
so that's my picture i definitely have
that skirt
oh zoom in zoom in on her zoom in on her
head
and your mom's just so high i'm so mad
that i'm this way the reason this makes
me happy the makeup has not improved
if esther's makeup looks good she paid
for it i'm so sorry to out you look at
those titties that is a cute outfit
though full abercrombie the low like
scrunchies
yes skirt i had that exact i want those
to come back also i was fully wearing a
fake tiffany bracelet that i bought in
new york oh new york was the best you
get all the like polo sport stuff
polo [__] yeah that really that is a
specific look and then this i found was
me so you see
i just went you hit an awkward stage not
when you were younger but in your late
teens i think like early teens
that's interesting but i've been
honestly my awkwardness is up and down
although honestly sometimes you come to
the show and i go what is that yeah no
i'm joking no but it's but it's great
that you took it but like here i am like
sexy at probably age 10. potty like
thick arms kind of like a milky a milky
body portalos with like a hot choker i
brought from my sister
a little evil very yes daria very dark
yeah very um the craft annie is homer
simpson barbie i think i'm daria barbie
what's kalila
there's a boy involved yeah
oh that's true you're dave girl barbie
no
you look exactly like him he's the
hottest foo fighter now
i'm assuming is that because all the
other ones are not alone because the one
just passed away that was the hottest oh
obviously the hottest mm-hmm
but that was a good thing
you're beautiful that better not be from
the ugliest no there's not this is my
beautiful like imagine my mom looking at
this picture i just want to say if i was
your doctor i would have figured this
[__] out
i would have fingered the [__] out of
that guy hey lila you are so you know
what i've been thinking about
and jealous you know what i've been
thinking about with kala
how unacceptable and disrespectful and
[__] up it was that you got a tit job
like how crazy you set the world the
world was off kilter when you did that
things were my whole body was off kilter
it's too much you're already too hot
look at those lips no it's true [__]
like you
oh no
is there anything better than that that
was my college that was my college uh
picture for the entire time that was my
are you brunette there
i just dirty blonde are you sure that's
not your twin brother is that amazing
look at my eyebrows too still over
plucked from high school
and i was going to the gym and i was
like oh it'll be cute i look like sporty
in it and then they squished all of our
pictures for some reason oh they yeah
actually i still think you look hot yeah
you do yeah there's one
i'm the one i'm the boy in the front
look at my little budding breasts that
never got bigger
say nasty it says vasser i mean how
funny is it to put a is it vassar in all
girls college by the way i think so yeah
but i've looked more i had umbra shorts
on you can't see and probably period
blood on them
i am so confused by your range
because you can really be
full hanson brother or like full
malibu barbie i look like taylor hansen
like exactly like him that and that's
that must be the issue then but he was
hot
he was hot he was like a hot girl hot
you guys
are you guys ready for how ugly i was
yeah taylor hanson young okay annie i
mean are you serious i looked like this
gorgeous man
now just picture just picture once again
that angelic face you just saw okay can
you go back to that
and you thought my mom like wow if you
were my mother where you think would you
think that is a pretty child it's a
beautiful yes and it's making me jealous
of anyone sperm because i wish i could
make a baby with you okay
you know what i would say i would say
like a race to me
oh wow
you look like a male like
70s 80s like star that is not okay
imagine my mother
if that was a guy i'd want to [__] it
those braces the metal mouth and it took
my lips away look at how cute and
luscious my baby lips were and then look
at that you guys
that is no wonder why my mom started
beating me harder at this age
can we talk about dipsy
because dipsy is an app full of hundreds
of short sexy audio stories designed by
women for women and they bring scenarios
to life with immersive soundscapes and
characters no matter who you're into or
what turns you on listen we know you
usually listen to us to wank off but we
actually have a better product that's
actually meant for that wake off to wank
it
twenty year winking
or winky you can find speaking of wank
you can find stories about that
intriguing co-worker with a british
accent oh hello there oh it's not you
there's no story where it's you esther
hello my ladies
new content is released every week so in
between listening to your favorite
stories again and again you can always
find something new to explore and dipsy
also has sleep stories wellness sessions
and now they offer written stuff are you
trying to be sexy while you're
delivering this so disgusting
look at her trying to be sexy for
listeners of the show dipsy is offering
an extended 30 day free trial when you
go to dipsystories.com
tuesday that's 30 days full access for
free when you go to d-i-p-s-e-a
stories dot com slash tuesday
she beat in the wrong place
the money maker oh i'm so glad this
picture exists because now you guys i am
not i now you have to like you know not
to love
and you have to let go of feeling like
you look like her because
you don't
i feel like i still think that even
this was a very
pimply
very
um scared very unsure young girl and
like i i take her with me and i love her
very kindly in my heart
so yeah i like this version of me it
makes me laugh because i'm like oh [__]
i just think about my mom who's so about
looks looks looks and i just
progressively started getting looking
weirder and weirder
well that was me with my weight like
when when i was gaining weight in
college that was not fun for my mom
oh really my parents never you my
brothers would be like jesus christ when
i'd come home
my brother would always my older brother
would always make some comment about me
getting fat right before i shot a tv
show oh no it would be like
timmy i'm gonna [__] i think he was
just teasing me but it was like the
worst tease like i was like they i can't
believe your brothers would make fun of
your weight that's like blowing my mind
well my parents well we were roasters so
it wasn't like coming from a mean place
it's like we just were a roasty family
my dad called me uh mustache barbie
my mom and i spent so much time like
bleaching our mustaches which is so
hilarious that's cute police doing your
mustaches was such a funny fad it's like
the sun would hit it and you just had
like a gold yeah
it was like a ticket to willy wonka he
looks like joe alwyn
for you
but um
he called my brother krusty the clown
max because he was on accutane so his
face was crusting off
and then he called timmy
my older brother he had a huge nose
before his deviated septum surgery
and i'm like i took a lot off but um
he
oh by the way i was thinking about this
there's this girl i know that got like
the boob job because she was like
pre-diagnosed with or like she they did
the testing
yeah yeah and
me and my friends were always like did
you have nose cancer too [__] how did
you get a nose dropped at the same time
well here's the thing here's what i'll
say about that
how do you stop well it's like while
you're down there you might as well
because it's like you don't want to be
under anesthesia like you know
frequently so it's like well [__] and
you're already gonna not be like in the
limelight because of your tips right so
it's like not two birds i'm getting this
out i stopped at a dermatologist i'm
getting this bottom remo mole removed
and
i'm like what else is going to happen to
me in this room once i'm there that
can't really be a certain that seems so
easy like let me know i would just go i
would just go with your teeth
um
i but i want it's like an uh
aesthetic dermatologist i know we call
it
beauty cosmetic cosmetic yeah yeah and i
was like
that's scary to go into that room like
what's gonna happen i've gone with
friends before
and because i've always like fantasized
about getting stuff done in my face and
i was like i and when i went i was like
okay like will you just like look at me
and say what you would do
thinking because you know we're so
insecure about different things like
because at the time i was really
insecure about laugh lines yeah
and
then he told me like what he what he
would do and it made me so much more
insecure i was like no i'm leaving can
you show the sexy picture of my brother
i sent you so how gorgeous right milky
titties
the shoulder off like really just so
so kidnappable just an adorable young
boy thank god we weren't in the catholic
church
gorgeous kid
and
okay so then see what he and that was
the time i look like [__] so now scroll
down and see what we turned into a
couple years later
he is the cartoon dog with acne
and i am
so cute so cute how old are you there
fourteen
weird that is making me uncomfortable
look at the thong
imprint on my
i mean how cute was i i had that little
like britney spears kind of chubby belly
oh my god 14. and look at max look at
his [__] face
how old is he there
he's their twins dumbass
wait he looks like a real 14 year old
like it's just like a dorky kid wait
guys can we see if my brother will pick
up when i call yeah he's never done it
i wanna this is the new game i wanna
play see if max will pick up oh every
week i know i'm so down
dana's watching love you
dana oh
we were going to play a game see if we
could get you to pick up because you've
never picked up my girl my entire life
and the celtics are killing it max
i love you you love me back
yeah i i can't believe this is the one
time i picked up i well i really only
picked up because i only have a few
minutes to talk
wait you would pick up i have to time my
schedule sometimes he's like annie i
can't talk i'm driving to work i'm like
the time you can talk
like esther whenever i try to talk to
her she's like i'm on a walk i'm like
the lightest cardio you could have
hi max
hi
we're looking at pictures i showed the
like sexy picture of you when you were
like nine
remember when your shoulder was out
oh yeah i forgot about that and then i
showed how ugly i was and how beautiful
you were and then how it flipped in this
picture
our modeling pictures max what is it
like being annie's twin
you know it's pretty good
well there's nothing you played about
you don't talk to me you talk to me once
a year
what are you gonna complain about on the
mic i got a free ride uh most of my
childhood because she was my twin sister
my parents never paid attention to me so
it's pretty nice
that's true
what would you say your worst childhood
memory is that me like
telling caitlyn schmidt heiser that you
had paid me to
to threaten him that was pretty pretty
messed up my office i was gonna say
pretty [__] up but um
uh that was pretty bad um what about the
towels was it the towels in front of
your friends what's the towels i would
come down
she happened to have a be taking a
shower every time my friends came over
it was not on purpose it was not on
purpose
attention i would tell you no i would
tell you if it was on purpose
and you would make one of my friends uh
for my friend for having big years which
i now retract i last episode i was
saying i really like big ears
but he like that was so he was so
sensitive about that like we never even
made fun of him for it well maybe i
helped him grow
there's he's like the nicest person i've
ever met i really like him he did once
do mushrooms and fall off a cliff and he
had a cane for prom
and i actually think i was gonna go to
prom with him and then you wouldn't let
me
that's not true
someone was going to take me to prom oh
i would have taken you to prison yeah
and i wouldn't have let it you didn't
let it happen so i never got to go to
prom so thank you
i can't believe this is like my dream
come true look at us he you guys
actually don't look like you but we look
like your mom and he looks so much like
your dad you think you look like dad
yeah for sure did you watch the video of
mom and dad hi in the grocery store
when i post it on twitter it's so funny
i didn't see it check it out all right
love you go celtics
love you too all right this is crazy
i love how he's like i only picked up
because i have a few minutes which is
great i'm fine with that yeah i don't
i'm rambling on there's times where
we've been on facetime and it's like
we're not the phone is up at the ceiling
i'm talking you might not even be in the
room i have gone you're getting dave to
get make you popcorn i drove to get gas
oh my god these flights how expensive
have flights just gotten i mean i'm like
are you gonna make me not fly first
class [__] i want to go get a
ticket to my show in west niagara it's
five thousand dollars to fly first class
what
that's like a usual um no that's usual
for like to fly to the philippines first
class is five grand it's like in europe
first game yeah what is regular class
twelve hundred dollars yes what
yes
what
cars have you ever
not noticed esther i haven't had to book
a trip it's the fuel
the cost of fuel let me tell you um a
friend of mine got a private company
that's the answer yeah
or a usual ticket that a ticket that i
usually pay uh maybe 300 bucks for is
1400 right now
yeah yeah
i'm gonna be in [__] a middle seat
getting coughed on getting covered
coughed on for [__] you can't afford
first
class i can afford anything so why don't
you just fly first class then oh no he's
picking okay guys no i like this no
thank you
no seriously if you can't afford like i
thought you could afford i can afford
anything all right then five [__]
first months
by the way guys houston this is my
houston outfit come see me
the flights are are packed really always
we just have to and everyone's so
excited to go back like the airlines
have us by the [__] nards dude they
got us they got us wait this sucks like
but that's why
merch
look guys airlines should start selling
merch airlines need to sell my merch i
will come on your plate if you sell my
merch like at the end when they're like
you can get 18 000 points if you sign up
for this card i'm like you can get eight
points
if you buy these pair of sunglasses
can't the airlines just like start
plastering ads all over the plane so
that it can be cheaper for us
wow
they do on the tvs
yeah
they don't care they're gonna they want
to make up for all the money they lost
and they have about two employees
and the employees aren't getting the
money
but so crazy how it just happened it
wasn't like an incremental increase it
was like overnight
guys
i went on family vacation we went to
long beach island in new jersey it was
so [__] fun todd couldn't come which
was actually good because i was able to
truly focus on my nephews and my nieces
couldn't come to max wasn't there so it
was like full nephew time and as a
future boy mom
i'm horrified
um they're so cute they're they're just
absolutely amazing but my one nephew has
turned six okay and he's really
interested in like people's bodies and
he wants to see you like undress always
be like
bear they call my dad bear like bear can
you oh yeah by the way follow my brother
on instagram he's the celtics guy
he's the best max letterman he's on tv a
lot we're tv twins but okay so
my six-year-old nephew
really wanted to see me naked like it
was like so such a weird position to be
in because like i just got into spray
tan so i was like
it's a good time i was like this
couldn't have looked better but um
he i came out of my bathroom
out of the bathroom in a towel a theme
in my family
came out in town and he goes
he looks at me and then he looks up at
the sky and he goes
please let that towel fall please
it was like the cutest thing but i don't
know how to deal with this because he's
sick so your subconscious is forming
till you're seven yeah so how i handle
this could turn him into like a subway
jerker offer like
so i was like um i just kept it's my
private parts but i wasn't like shaming
him about it because
but it is like
what am i doing
that's crazy because it's not like in
europe they're all naked so it's like
people are seeing the bodies of he
wasn't like
let me see he wasn't like bumping into
the couch or anything he and he was
asking my dad too like he just wanted to
see people's bodies
but it was like a part of me was like
should i just like i don't know what i
mean what does a mom and dad say
we don't want to talk about this i was
like sort of like uh
timmy thinks it's funny because he
remembers being that age and stuff
but it was just like it was so cute when
he looked up at the sky
oh by the way one of my nephews my
family's not religious one of my nephews
goes to a he's uh turning four or he
just turned four he goes to a
uh daycare at a church
so he just said it doesn't sound like a
good combo he says all these god things
but nobody else he'll just be like
they were walking by like a house that
was being constructed and he went
mom does god make that house like he
just says stuff like that all the time
it's so funny and so cute that's so cute
to randomly have a religious family
there's just one four-year-old religious
kid and nobody else
i used to up until i came to america i
was a very pious young lass tell us more
i was um very very into god and very
fearful of god i prayed every night and
then you came here and stopped and got
molested more than anyone has ever
gotten maybe you should have kept
praying girl i i should have prayed
harder i wouldn't even if i would say
like [__] i would get on my hands and
knees that night you know
dear god i'm really sorry i said the s
word like please forgive me
i was really afraid for what might
happen to me if i like cursed and
stopped who taught you that i was raised
in a very like catholic um you know
country so like i went to
um my last couple years in the
philippines i went to an all-girls
catholic school
you're just it's just around you you're
scared of god carlos do you did you have
that too like scared of swearing
no i wouldn't say god damn it though
like i grew up going to a catholic
daycare too i just
when you're told things before you're
four or something it's just did they
tell you don't get it they said never
say don't get it never say i'd like a
haircut
[Laughter]
never say a curse word take the lord's
name in vain or say i would like a
haircut well this is why
you know um r.i.p to my cecil um she
used to show me her private parts all
the time against my wife but like
what was that right sentence
um so my my teeth are growing up so
she's my aunt um she was a very sexually
um like open person she always like
brought around like her lover it's like
here this is your new uncle and you'd be
like hi uncle so and so with it like
rotated everything you're gonna be out
of here but she was just a hot woman
she even well into her 50s she was just
a gorgeous woman
um up until the day she died she cared
to put like she she was she passed from
cancer but even the day before she put
lipstick on like she was just very was
it has cancer
getting blood in the butt no it wasn't
it was was that it's actually a bladder
bladder yeah colon cancer is technically
acid from there from getting back to the
energy no no there's no there can't be
anything you can't there's no cancers
that are sexually transmitted yeah you
can you can get from hpv and stuff like
that oh that's right how annoying is
that yeah it's annoying it's annoying
that an s you know it's something weak
we just got an hpv i've gone hbv yeah
and you got rid of you got the scraping
out um so yeah i got the
i hated that i was like really young too
yeah yeah because mine but it's it's
preventative for like cervical cancer
but i still got the shot the gardasil
afterwards even yeah i had like aged out
of the shot i was like oh i never got it
the shot or i don't think
or hpv yeah it's hard to tell like most
people don't have
will you look in and see yeah gladly
i see an agent
but
my aunt would always just show her [__]
and her nipples and even as i got a
little bit older was it like a was it
like it's a little easy to show your
[__] like you have to like no but she
you know what you do some people shave
[__] of course it's hard for there's a
forest around it
a lot of people can show their vaginas
very easily there is a forest right now
right now don't act like there isn't
ever so full of [__] when i went home to
the philippines at 19 i hadn't been home
in a long time i hadn't seen her a long
time the first thing she did was come to
the room let me show you something and
and she was like look how good my [__]
looks she goes like how old are you i
was like 19. she goes show me your she's
like look mine still looks better than
yours and she was like look at my
nipples look how perfect we are philip
you know huh yeah because i see her
[__] within 10 seconds of being at
her house and i'm always like it looks
better than mine it's great she has a
beautiful situation
wha why
so she was showing it off she was
showing she would show it off to anyone
who had the time is that illegal to show
your [__]
i was 19. i was like
like you're asking like you need to know
for yourself
like i'm thinking i'm not a male
comedian i'm thinking of throwing
showing this snatch to a youngin
all right you guys well thank you so
much for tuning in this week um that was
a um
beautifully strange ending
so strange
um please like and subscribe and tell
your friends to join you on this journey
of mental unhealth with us yes
you